help is on its way but it's coming in
bit by bit
getting vital supplies to these remote
areas of eastern afghanistan is clearly
a challenge in itself but it's needed
now more than ever
after a plea for help to the
international community humanitarian
assistance was sent by south korea
pakistan and india with more pledged
it's not only these two provinces of
ghost and bhagtika but there have also
been floodings throughout afghanistan
and many districts have been affected
afghans are facing huge problems now
in the capital kabul they're loading up
all they can to send to the areas
affected but the government here said
they don't have enough
for many countries there is a real
resistance to deal directly with the
taliban instead they say they'll send
support via aid agencies a combination
of a poor track record on human rights
and freedoms with a lack of
infrastructure means supporting
afghanistan in a time of need is proving
difficult
whatever they do have has to battle
challenging terrain and patchy
communications to get to those who need
it
it's only just over 100 miles away but
getting here from kabul can take a whole
day
and once here this is the scene
with homes reduced to rubble people are
left with no choice other than to sleep
on the ruins of where their beds once
lay
our people are very weak financially and
they don't have work
even in the next 20 years they won't be
able to rebuild their houses because of
the financial crisis we're calling on
our government and other international
organizations like ngos to help us
but in these disasters it's always the
children who suffer
officials believe over a hundred have so
far been killed and those who survived
have now lost everything
including their family
this devastation is of course down to
tuesday's rumbling earthquake but this
was a government simply not prepared and
so as they wait for more aid the taliban
will no doubt have to reflect on how
they can engage with the rest of the
world in the future to ensure when help
is needed once more they're not
abandoned again in zaman rashid sky news
in kabul